BUT FIRST, THE H AND CHAOS
CAMPAIGN.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
NOW IMAGINE IF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF LET’S SAY
GEORGIA HAD SPONSORED A VOTER
REGISTRATION DRIVE, WITH
BALLOONS, POSTERS, SIGN-UP
STATIONS, IT WOULD BE MANNED BY
EITHER PARTY VOLUNTEERS ON THE
SIDEWALK LET’S SAY OUTSIDE A
SHOPPING MALL.
THEN A VAN PULLS UP, AND A
DRIVER ROLLS DOWN THE WINDOW,
BUT THEN HE HITS THE GAS.
AND HE PLOWS THROUGH THE TENT,
LUCKILY LUCKILY NO INJURIES.
THIS STORY, OF COURSE, WOULD
LEAD EVERY MAJOR NEWSCAST,
REGARDLESS OF THE FACT THAT
TRUNCATING REPORTERS WOULD JUMP
TO THE CONCLUSION THAT HE WAS
PARTLY THE IMPETUS FOR SUCH A
HEINOUS ACT.
WELL, ON SATURDAY, 27-YEAR-OLD
GREGORY KIM WAS ARRESTED IN
JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA, FOR
PLOWING INTO A REPUBLICAN GET
OUT THE VOTE TEND OUTSIDE A
WALMART.
THE G.O.P. OF DeVOL COUNTY
SAID THAT SIX VOLUNTEERS WERE
TARGETED.
THIS ASSAILANT WASN’T REGISTERED
TO VOTE, HE DID NOT HAVE MUCH OF
A SOCIAL MEDIA PRESENCE.
THE DeVOL COUNTY DEMOCRATS
RELEASED THE STATEMENT SAYING
THEY ARE THANKFUL THAT THE
PERPETRATOR OF THIS COWARDLY ACT
HAS BEEN APPREHENDED BY POLICE
AND CONTINUE TO CALL FOR
CIVILITY DURING THE CYCLE.
GOOD FOR THEM FOR CONDEMNING
COME ABOUT THAT SENTIMENT WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN ENOUGH HAD THE
SHOE BEEN ON THE OTHER FOOT.
NOW IT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THERE HAS POTENTIALLY BEEN NO
RESPONSE FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
2020 CANDIDATES ABOUT THIS, WHO
CLAIM TO CARE SO DEEPLY ABOUT
SUCH ISSUES.
>> IN THE 21ST CENTURY, VOTING
RIGHTS ON THE KIND OF VOTER
SUPPRESSION WE HAVE SEEN CANNOT
STAND.
>> WE NEED TO REPEAL EVERYONE OF
THE VOTER SUPPRESSION LAWS THAT
IS OUT THERE RIGHT NOW.
>> COVERED THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS ARE PRETRYING TO
SUPPRESS THE VOTE.
THAT IS INCREDIBLY UNDEMOCRATIC,
UN-AMERICAN.
>> Laura: VOTER SUPPRESSION,
VOTER INTIMIDATION MATTERS TO
THE DEMOCRATS.
DON’T YOU THINK THAT IS PRETTY
INTIMIDATING WHEN A VAN DRIVE
THROUGH A REGISTRATION TENT?
NOW I GUESS IT IS POSSIBLE, BUT
MY OPINION IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY,
THAT ANTI-TRUMP RAGE WASN’T PART
OF THE MOTIVATION HERE, WE WILL
FIND OUT MORE AS THE DAYS GO ON.
BUT PREDICTABLY, THE MEDIA HAS
BARELY COVERED THE STORY AT ALL.
THINK ABOUT THIS, THE ATTACK
HAPPENED ON SATURDAY.
AND AS OF SUNDAY MORNING, ONLY
NBC SUNDAY TODAY COVERED IT.
AND ONLY FOR 25 SECONDS.
NOW, REMEMBER WHAT PRECEDED THIS
FLORIDA ATTACK.
THINK ABOUT THE DARK AND
SINISTER WAY PROMINENT PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT,
THE OUTCOME OF HIS IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL, AND AMERICA IN GENERAL.
>> ONCE THE FASCISTS GETS POWER,
THEY DON’T GIVE IT UP.
YOU HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
LIFE.
>> PRESIDENT-ELECT AS A
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
>> THERE IS NO EXONERATION, NO
VINDICATION, NO REAL ACQUITTAL
FROM A FAKE TRIAL.
>> WE HAVE A RACIST SOCIETY FROM
TOP TO BOTTOM.
>> THIS MAY HAVE STARTED AS AN
ANTI-TRUMP MOVEMENT, BUT IN SOME
YOU JUST SAW, IT HAS BECOME AN
ANTI-AMERICA MOVEMENT.
FACE IT, TRUMPS POLICIES, THEY
ARE LARGELY WORKING.
AND AT LEAST HALF OF AMERICA
SUPPORTS THEM.
SO I WOULD QUESTION, ARE THEY
ALL ILLEGITIMATE?
62 MILLION PEOPLE VOTED FOR HIM
LAST TIME AROUND, OR ARE THEY
JUST DEPORTABLE, OR ARE THEY
JUST RACIST OR STUPID?
THIS WHOLE THING IS GETTING OUT
OF HAND, IT SMACKS OF TOTAL
DESPERATION ON THE DEMOCRATS
PART.
NOW WE STILL DON’T KNOW WHICH
FOLKS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CITIZEN JOURNALISTS BRAIN BLEED
LAST YEAR, ONLY ANDREW YANG AND
JOE BIDEN EVEN CONDEMNED THAT
ATTACK.
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP IN CITIES
SUCH AS PORTLAND, OREGON,
BERKELEY, YOU HAVE SEEN THIS
CRAZINESS, A LOT ON THE LEFT
COAST WHERE THE RAMPAGE TOOK
PLACE.
THEY LARGELY TURNED A BLIND EYE
TO LEFTIST VIOLENCE.
POLICE ARE GIVEN STAND-DOWN
ORDERS, AND MASS ANITIFA
RADICALS HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
WAIL ON ANYONE WHO GETS IN THEIR
WAY WITH IMPUNITY.
ESPECIALLY FROM SUPPORTERS, NO
CONSEQUENT.
FEW, IF ANY ARRESTS.
AND THESE PEOPLE CLAIM TRUMP IS
THE ONE STOKING HATRED, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME?
THE NONSTOP, MOST CRUEL
DEMONIZATION OF THE PRESIDENT
AND ANYONE WHO WORKS FOR HIM OR
SUPPORTS HIM A COURSE 24/7.
AND IT IS NOT JUST BY KNIT CAP
WEARING BASEMENT ROLLERS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, THIS IS HAPPENING
AT THE HANDS OF SUPPOSEDLY
RESPECTED MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT.
>> LET ME BE VERY CLEAR, YOU ARE
STUPID AS.
YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE I
SAY SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED AROUND
HOUSEHOLD APPLIANCES, YOU WILL
TAKE OFF SOME FINGERS IF NOT
YOUR ENTIRE HAND.
THE ENTIRE STUPIDITY, HE IS NOT
MENTALLY OKAY.
>> HE IS RACIST, SEXIST,
HOMOPHOBIC, PRESIDENT IN
HISTORY.
>>>> Laura: THESE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO CLAIM TO BE SO WOKE,
SO COMPASSIONATE, SO TOLERANT.
BUT FOR THEM AT THE END, RIDDING
US OF TRUMP OF COURSE, ALWAYS
JUSTIFIES THE MEANS.
NOW REMEMBER THE MOCK
ASSASSINATION OF TRUMP DURING
THAT SHAKESPEARE IN THE PARK?
>> AN ACTOR DRESSED TO LOOK JUST
LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP AS HE IS
ASSASSINATED ON STAGE.
LOOK AT HIS CHARACTER IS STABBED
TO DEATH.
AND THERE IS NO MISTAKING THE
TRUMP CONNECTION.
>> Laura: TRUMP HAD ONLY BEEN
IN OFFICE FOR A COUPLE MONTHS,
MEMBER KATHY GRIFFIN LOADING UP
HIS SEVERED HEAD?
OR NBA STARS AND COACHES WHO
HAVE BEEN BOUGHT OFF BY CHINA
BUT FEEL MORALLY SUPERIOR WHEN
TRASHING TRUMP?
>> I HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE ANGRY
AND DISGUSTED AT THE SITUATION
THAN I AM NOW OUR COUNTRY IS AN
EMBARRASSMENT IN THE WORLD DID
YOU NUMBER ONE JOB IN AMERICA,
SOMEONE WHO DOESN’T UNDERSTAND
THE PEOPLE.
HE REALLY DOESN’T GIVE ABOUT THE
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: OR THE VICIOUS
ANTI-CAVANAUGH PROTESTS.
>> THEY ARE STILL TRYING TO GET
ANY SUPREME COURT, BY THE WAY.
THEY KEPT BANGING AND NO ONE
ANSWERED.
OF COURSE THERE IS OUR FAVORITE
ROBERT "FOREVER YOUNG" DE NIRO.
>> THIS IDIOT IS A PRESIDENT, HE
IS A FOOL.
COME ON.
HE IS LIKE A GANGSTER, HE IS
TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU WANT TO
PUNCH PEOPLE IN THE FACE.
>> Laura: THE MAN JUST NEEDS
BETTER LINES, COME ON BOBBY.
NOW WHILE DEMOCRATS BLAME TRUMP
HIMSELF FOR CREATING AN
ATMOSPHERE OF FURY AND RACISM,
THE PRESIDENT WITH SMART
POLICIES HAS DONE MORE TO HELP
THE BLACK COMMUNITY THAN ANY
PRESIDENT IN THE MODERN ERA.
IT IS THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
MOST RADICAL ELEMENTS WHO ARE
FOSTERING A TOXIC AND DANGEROUS
ATMOSPHERE.
NOW IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO JUST
DISAGREE WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
POLICIES, THEY TRY TO STAY IN
AND DAY OUT TO DESTROY HIM.
AND HIS FAMILY.
BUT THEY FAILED.
THEIR VICIOUSNESS ISN’T JUST
DIRECTED AT PRESIDENT TRUMP,
LEFT-WING ACTIVISTS ARE TURNING
TO ATTACKING POLICE NOW TOO.
DURING IMPEACHMENT, THE CHAOS AT
NEW YORK’S GRAND CENTRAL STATION
CARRIED OUT BY ANTIFA AND OCCUPY
WALL STREET, IT DIDN’T GET THE
COVERAGE IT DESERVED.
>> NO COPS, A RACIST USA.
>> Laura: WHAT A DISGRACE, THE
PROTESTERS ARE SO COURAGEOUS IN
THEIR MASKS, COWARDS EVERY LAST
ONE OF THEM.
THEY WOULD BE THE FIRST ONE TO
WET THEIR PANTS IF THEY REALLY
NEEDED A POLICE OFFICER AND AN
EMERGENCY.
THEY DISRUPTED TRANSIT, ONE OF
THE BUSIEST TRAIN STATIONS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THIS WASN’T EVEN ABOUT WANTING
FREE STUFF, THEY WERE TESTING
BILL de BLASIO AND CHRIS
CUOMO.
WILL THERE BE REPERCUSSIONS FOR
THIS?
NO THERE NEVER IS, BILL
DE BLASIO IS HATED BY THE
POLICE FOR GOOD REASON.
HE DOESN’T HAVE THEIR BACKS, AND
THEY KNOW IT.
THIS HAS CREATED A POISONOUS,
AND FRANKLY IT’S CREATED A
DANGEROUS DYNAMIC FOR THE PEOPLE
OF THE CITY.
AND IT IS NOT GOING TO END UNTIL
ONCE AGAIN THEY ELECT SOMEONE
LIKE RUDY GIULIANI WHO WAS
TOUGH, BUT FAIR.
AND THINGS ARE NOW EVEN WORSE,
NYPD OFFICERS WERE TARGETED INTO
SEPARATE ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT
THIS PAST WEEKEND.
THE POLICE UNIT SAY BILL
DE BLASIO’S ERRATIC IS TO BLAME
BLAME.
>> THEY ARE LISTENING AND COMING
AFTER US ON THE STREETS, THE
FIRST THING I THOUGHT WHEN I GOT
THIS CALL, SOMEONE WAS SHOT AND
12 HOURS LATER, I SAID THEY ARE
HUNTING US.
THEY ARE HUNTING US.
>> Laura: THIS IS AN
UNTOLERABLE DISGRACE, THEY ARE
SO VIOLENT AND DID THEY DEMONIZE
POLICE.
THE ONLY THING STANDING BETWEEN
US AND THEM IS THE POLICE.
AND IN AN ECONOMY WERE IN SO ARE
BENEFITING, THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD
SEE THAT ALL OF THIS RAGE IS NOT
GETTING MUCH TRACTION WITH
REGULAR AMERICA.
AFTER A WHILE, IF YOU KEEP
RAGING, AND YOU JUST LOOK
IMPOTENT.